(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
- Oh, my gosh.
- Hi.
(audience applauds)
- Have y'all met before?
- No, we've never met, but
come on, eighth appearance,
I see you.
- Hey, look at that.
We've, we've actually met before.
- Stop it.
- Wait.
- Yeah.
We dated in high school.
Oh yeah, that's right.
(Kelly laughs)
- That was my boo, we went
to prom and everything.
- He was not memorable.
(Danielle laughs)
You were the one that
laughed at him all the time,
he was talking about.
(Kelly laughs)
- That's me.
- Listen, but he had a great suit at prom,
let me tell you that.
- [Kelly] I tell you, yeah.
I bet you were the guy
that she wanted to show up
looking like Dumb and
Dumber in those suits, like.
(Danielle chuckles)
Were you?
- I'd dare you.
- I think you were probably funny then.
- I don't remember.
- Okay.
- What you don't remember,
is that we had a TLC theme,
so we had silk pajamas, it was
from the "Creep" video, so.
- Okay, I love that outfit.
- That's what we were doing.
- I still have them.
- Yeah, crazy, sexy, cool.
Okay, so wait, I hear that you're working
with Eddie Murphy now, is that right?
- Oh, God, yes.
- That's incredible.
- Yes, I, this is my first movie,
it is called "Candy Cane Lane".
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It is, Eddie Murphy is at the helm
with Tracee Ellis Ross and
Robin Thede and like...
- Oh, my God, this cast, wow.
- It's incredible.
We just did our first Zoom
table read over the holidays
and I was shaking, because I'm
such a huge Eddie Murphy fan.
When I was 13, from like 13 to 16,
I would watch, rewatch all of his SNLs
and all of his movies and...
- So incredible.
- Everything, so like, to
be able to even see my name
with his, is just a huge dream come true.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
(audience applauds)
So, what your character in "Ghost",
is a ghost from the 1920s?
- Yes, she's a...
- That's a fun costume.
- 1920s prohibition era jazz singer.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Danielle] Her name is Alberta Haynes.
Yes, oh my God.
(audience applauds)
Child, look at my girl, Rebecca.
(Danielle laughs)
(audience applauds)
- So, I didn't know you sang as well.
You do everything.
- Listen, I didn't know
I sang either, Kelly,
to be honest.
(Danielle laughs)
- Wait, are you one of
those people that like,
the actors that's like, "Sure I can sing".
- Special skills, I was like,
"Alto, that's what it is, right?"
(Danielle laughs)
So, they cast me.
I actually sang in my
audition just in the lines
and they were like, "Oh,
she must be able to sing".
I was like, "Y'all, I'm
just playing around".
So, I've actually had
to start singing lessons
during the process.
I've done dance lessons and
I wanna learn the Charleston.
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- [Danielle] And all the
dances from the time period.
And I just think playing
this role is so iconic,
because as a black artist,
the 1920s were so incredible
for us at that time, culturally.
And like, I just wanna give her,
her just do and all those
artists that came before me, so.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Playing this role is just a dream.
(audience applauds)
- I love like, as an actor, like,
y'all get to learn all
these like, different skills
for your role, that's cool.
Then you end up like
learning all these, these,
these cool things that nobody
really gets a chance to do
or...
- I know.
- Takes the time to do.
- It's amazing.
- Yeah.
- And it's like, the best
role I've ever played so far
in my career.
- That's cool.
- Also, getting to work with
the ensemble, Rose McIver,
who I know has been on the
show and Utkarsh Ambudkar.
They're...
- Yeah.
- Are, are the best lead
leads in the business
and we are just so honored to
be working with them weekly.
- I love your cast, we've had them here.
And Rose actually said that
y'all get very competitive,
like it's a competitive cast.
- Y'all, we almost didn't
have a season two, okay?
- What? What was the game?
- Okay, it was between Mancala,
but I'm gonna tell you the
real game was Scrabble.
- I love Scrabble.
- Scrabble almost took us out.
Richie Moriarty, who plays Pete and
Asher Grodman who plays
Trevor, the guy with no pants.
They're very good at Scrabble
and I thought I was great.
But Richie had spelled sommelier
and got a triple word score.
- What?
- And then, used all of his letters
and still to this day, I think he cheated.
I'm like, how did you spell sommelier
with all these letters?
And we stopped talking for months.
(audience and Kelly laugh)
Months, months.
Richie, I know you cheated.
- That's an incredible word.
- Yeah, it's, it's serious.
- Yeah.
- It's, it's no joke.
So, we actually decided
as a cast, you know,
we're not gonna do Scrabble no more.
We're just gonna let it go.
- This is, this is
literally me and my sister
and my mother, we'll play Scrabble
and I don't even know why we play, y'all.
My mother, every time
almost flips the board
and she, she is like, she's
like, "That is not a word".
It's always she and my
sister going at each other.
It's the most enjoyable
time with my family for me.
Are y'all competitive? Are you?
- Yeah, I'm dyslexic, I can't spell...
(beeping)
(audience laughs)
- Oh, my God.
- Oh, I, I look at Scrabble, I'm like,
"Yeah, these seem to be
all spelled correctly".
(audience laughs)
They're all in front of me, yeah.
- Oh, my God, it's amazing how games
that shouldn't be subjective
can still cause such drama.
- That's me and Connect Four too.
(Kelly laughs)
Connect Four is, is, I'm a liar.
- I can play Connect Four.
- [Danielle] Yeah, we'll do it, I'm ready.
- I'm good at that.
- I'm ready, I'm ready.